this number of words you know is sort of
a an indication of your potential in the
language hi there steve kaufman here
today and today i'm going to talk about
something very important in language
learning maybe in some ways the most
important thing
words how do we learn them
why are they important how do we use
them remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a review i
do appreciate it
so
when i started with my son mark
interlink and i was doing a lot of
thinking about language learning in fact
i did a lot of research
uh read books in english in swedish in
german
in french on this whole subject of
language learning i came to the
conclusion
that the single most i call it the
gordian knot
the single simplest sort of evaluation
of where we are in a language is how
many words we know
all right get a lot of criticism people
say no you can be fluent
with a few words but in fact you can't
and i'll explain why
and so before i get going though i want
to show you that i don't just sort of
rely on my own experience although
obviously
anybody talking about say language
learning is going to refer to their own
experience but i also did a lot of
research and i had a look you'll see
behind me i have all these books i have
cds that i've listened to
but
i went and looked at my uh bookshelf
here so here's on the books learning
vocabulary in another language isp
nation
all right
i have lots of books on second a
language acquisition rod ellis he does
talk about vocabulary acquisition
second
language vocabulary acquisition
norbert schmidt vocabulary in language
teaching
and what do we got here again norbert
schmidt this is from cambridge
description acquisition and pedagogy
vocabulary so it's not as if i haven't
looked into it i found that most of
these books were unnecessarily
complicated
again i i tend to look for the occam's
raisin razor raisin occam's raisin
arkham's razor occam's razor in other
words the simplest explanation of a
phenomenon the gordian knot and to me
words are the key sort of you know
measure of where we are in a language
and how we acquire them actually is
quite simple
there's a lot of talk about you know you
must read content that only has a small
percentage of new words in it or that
you have to meet a word so many times
before you'll learn it and all of that
is almost irrelevant to me
learning words again you'll not be
surprised to hear me say this is all
about acquiring them naturally
it's not because you say i want to learn
5 000 words that you're going to learn 5
000 words it's not because you
deliberately sit there with a stash of
of
cards flash cards or because you read
the dictionary that you're going to
acquire all those words
it may be something you enjoy doing it
is a form of exposure to those words but
ultimately it's going to be the amount
that you are exposed to the language in
a meaningful environment
that is pleasant to you that is
conducive to the brain gradually
acquiring these words that's going to do
it it's a bit like if you go up to a
girl or if you're a girl you go up to a
guy or whatever you're going i want to
be your girlfriend or your boyfriend
that's not going to do it you actually
have to it's more indirect than that you
can't just say i want to acquire all
these words what happens is you're
acquiring them in the background all
right
and that's why
when we created link we wanted to have a
measure
of the words you're learning
and i will show you a snapshot of all
the different languages that i have
learned on link and how many words i
know in each of those languages and that
is a statistic that's quite encouraging
but it's not an absolute number um i may
know words in language more words in a
certain language than in another
language but because i'm working on uh
persian right now i can speak it better
than czech perhaps although i know far
more words in czech than i do in persian
if i were to go back to chuck i would
quickly recover it so that this number
of words you know is sort of a an
indication of your potential in the
language it's also relative so in some
languages like the slavic languages
there are many forms of essentially the
same word
that means that the word count the way
we count them at link where we count
each form of the word as a different
word that word count is going to be a
bit bloated compared to other languages
where that's not the case
so it's not an absolute number but it's
an indication it's an indication that
you're making progress you know say six
months ago i knew 5 000 words now i know
20 000 words so
those moments when i feel i'm not
progressing in the language the plateau
the doldrums it reminds me that in fact
you have acquired a lot of words now
some people say
what does it mean to know a word all
right
you can't claim to know a word unless
you can use it
say some people i don't agree with that
i am very much a proponent of acquiring
a large passive vocabulary and if you
understand a word in at least one
context you know that word at least for
that context
if you come across it again and it
doesn't make sense in that context and
you look it up again and you find that
there's another scope of meaning for
that word fine but passive vocabulary is
what it's all about because passive
vocabulary is the door
to
reading in the language understanding
movies in the language having meaningful
conversations in the language all of
which opens you up to meaningful
compelling input without the passive
vocabulary you can't do those things so
i have always been against the idea of
trying to make sure that you can use
every word you learn
go to you know conversation class try to
use it
if i have an opportunity to use whatever
little i've learned in the language i
will do so
and typically even at a relatively low
vocabulary level i may start having
sessions once or twice a week with a
tutor because it kind of helps me a
little bit it tends to make my input
activities more
interesting for me
but fundamentally i rely on
increasing my word count my passive
vocabulary because that's what's going
to enable me to learn the language and
if we acquire these words
in what i would call an honest way which
means through massive listening and
reading we are not only acquiring the
words we are acquiring familiarity with
the language because
again it's a bit like that i've often
referred to sort of the dog races where
the dogs chase a mechanical rabbit if we
are trying to increase our vocabulary
that drags us through all this content
and as we are listening and reading our
brain is becoming more and more familiar
with the language
increasing our comprehension level
increasing our passive vocabulary so
that we can then do more things in the
language including engage with people in
meaningful conference conversations
that's not to say that i don't
occasionally
you know
do the sort of uh
flash cards predominantly phrases by the
way i very much recommend
doing flashcards for phrases rather than
individual words i will sometimes pick
up interesting dictionaries for example
you know i like this uh you know legend
site grunt vouchers
so i can see german and russian side by
side it's just fun to do that i don't
know what it's doing for me but it's fun
to do that is similarly i have one here
for portuguese grundwatch portuguese so
i can see portuguese and german side by
side which is fun and expands my sense
of the language similarly here we have a
slobneck ruskocheski czeskorowski
slovnik so i can see
russian and czech side by side these are
fun things to do there's nothing wrong
with doing them but fundamentally the
words are acquired through
input
and uh
as we acquire these words we are
acquiring the language and so if your
word count at link is now up to ten
thousand twenty thousand thirty thousand
it's not necessarily something that you
can brag to other people about but it is
an indication that you are progressing
in the language now i did make some
notes here
but i'm not going to worry about it i
had a few other things that i wanted to
say but i can't remember them but i just
want to leave you with that thought that
work on your vocabulary work on words
and phrases
uh if you have more opportunity to speak
and if you speak more you'll speak
better more fluently but you have to
have that basis in the language which
comes from having a large passive
vocabulary because the native speakers
that you will encounter
either face to face individually or with
a group or in movies or books or
podcasts they all have
in almost every case a larger passive
vocabulary in your target language than
you do and to understand them and
interact with them and and benefit from
interacting with them you need that
large passive vocabulary so there you
have it words how we acquire words it
still comes back to that basic
massive input
good luck and i will leave you a couple
of videos that i have done previously on
the same subject hopefully i don't
contradict myself
bye for now